yeah I think you could say that okay um
I mean don't forget uh Thames has
already drawn on some 500 million pounds
worth of uh equities from its
shareholder earlier this year uh it has
a variety of shareholders they include
Omas which is a giant uh Canadian
pension fund and USS which is the
University's super annuation scheme
which is basically the pension fund for
uh Britain's uh University lecturers
past and present so their those
shareholders they've already put in 500
million pounds this year they've agreed
this morning to put in another 750
million pounds but the company's warning
that further Equity fundraisings will be
required over the next regulatory period
that is due to run from 2025 to the end
of the decade and Tim's saying that it
will have to put in uh it will expect it
shareholders to put in another two and a
half billion pounds over that period to
support the Investments required in the
network now uh thames's Financial
circumstance stances have been laid out
today the company's also published its
Financial results these cover the year
to the end of March and during that time
the company reported a pre-tax loss on
an underlying basis of 82.6 million
pounds now that actually represents an
improvement uh the comparable figure
during the previous 12 months was 895
and a half million pounds and really
what is uh weighing down on this company
is the uh is its debts it's financing
costs during the last 12 months with
some 476 million pounds and during the
last 12 months its overall debt position
has increased from 12 and a half billion
pounds just yes shy of 14 billion pounds
that really sort of spells out the need
that's why new Equity is required